it's not going to be 45 seconds I can't
say that right now I want to dedicate
this to my parents and to my brother and
sister to my friend Robert Garlock who
is not with us anymore and to everyone
who has helped me from the beginning and
you all know who you are and I thank you
from my heart
I I grew up in a place called alcovendas
where this was not a very realistic
dream and I always the night of the
Academy Awards I stay up to watch the
show
and and I always felt that this ceremony
was a moment of unity for the world
because art in any form is and has been
and will always be our universal
language and we should do everything we
can to protect its survival is
thank you so much
thank you
[Music]